Der Gumshoe: der erste Turnschuh
aus recyceltem Kaugummi.
Zumindest die Sohle besteht aus Abfällen
der niederländischen Hauptstadt Amsterdam.
Die 23-jährige Ökonomie-Studentin
Soraya Menara ist begeistert
von der Idee und sichert sich beim
Verkaufsstart eines der ersten 500 Paare.
Sie sind sehr bequem. Ich mag die Farbe  –
und besonders die Sohle
mit dem Stadtplan von Amsterdam.
Der Stadtplan ist in die Sohle eingraviert,
schließlich stammt der Rohstoff
von ebendiesen Straßen. Er scheint eine
Art erneuerbare Ressource zu sein:
1.500 Tonnen Kaugummi werden auf
niederländische Straßen gespuckt
– jedes Jahr. Dabei vergehen 25 Jahre,
bevor Kaugummi biologisch abgebaut ist:
ein Problem für jede Großstadt.
Wir müssen viele Leute bezahlen,
um die Straßen zu reinigen.
Kaugummis sind ein großes Müll-Problem.
Wenn man auf die Straße schaut,
sieht man überall Kaugummi.
Die Menschen nehmen es gar nicht mehr
wahr. Aber wenn man sich darauf
konzentriert, sieht man, dass es mehr
Kaugummi als Straße gibt.
Um auf dieses Problem aufmerksam zu
machen, ließen die Macher des Gumshoe
250 Kilogramm Kaugummi von den Straßen
der niederländischen Metropole aufsammeln.
Shaquille Gunther vom Amsterdamer
Modelabel "Explicit Wear"
entwarf das Design. Hilfe bei der
Verarbeitung des Kaugummis
gab es von der britischen
Recycling-Firma Gumdrop –
für den Designer eine spannende
Herausforderung.
Wir mussten erst einmal ausprobieren,
ob es funktioniert.
Wir sind schließlich die ersten,
die das Material nutzen.
Aber es ist sehr innovativ und
man kann viel damit machen.
Die Idee für alternative,
recycelte Materialien ist in
der Schuh-Branche nicht neu:
Die spanische Firma Piñatex
hat eine vegane Lederalternative
aus Ananasblättern entwickelt.
Auch aus Fischhäuten, die sonst
im Abfall landen würden,
wird Leder hergestellt.
Das deutsche Label "Nanai"
fertigt daraus unter anderem Schuhe.
Und der Sportartikelhersteller Adidas
hat eine ganze Schuhkollektion,
die aus Ozeanmüll produziert wird.
Ganz nebenbei kann durch solche
Projekte für ein bestimmtes Problem
sensibilisiert werden.
Wir hätten auch eine Werbekampagne
machen können: Schmeißt keine Kaugummis
auf die Straße!
Aber das hätte nicht funktioniert.
Das klingt wie eine Mutter: Tu das nicht!
Da hört niemand zu. Aber mit so etwas
Kreativem wie einem Turnschuh
bekommt man eine ganz andere
Aufmerksamkeit. Und vielleicht denkt
jemand beim nächsten Mal
an den Gumshoe
und schmeißt seinen Kaugummi
nicht auf die Straße.
Der Schuh passt damit perfekt in den
nachhaltigen Lifestyle,
der sich bei jungen Großstädtern
immer mehr durchsetzt.
Sneaker aus alten Kaugummis sind
dafür ein ideales Statussymbol.
Sie sind neu, sie sind knallig,
sie sind nachhaltig –
und damit absolut instagrammable,
wie man schon
wenige Stunden nach Verkaufsstart
sieht.
Ganz billig ist der Kaugummi-Schuh
jedoch nicht: 200 Euro kostet das Paar.
Ich finde den Gumshoe innovativ,
weil er durch Upcycling die Straßen
von Amsterdam ein bisschen
sauberer macht.
Ich denke, es ist der beste Weg,
um junge Leute zu erreichen,
mit einem coolen Projekt auf das Problem
aufmerksam zu machen.
So erreicht man auch die Jugendlichen,
die die Kaugummis einfach ausspucken.
Stylishe Schuhe, die im besten Falle helfen,
die Straßen ein bisschen sauberer zu halten.